ah
[Música]
el mar del sur de china es estratégico
no solo por los yacimientos bajo sus
aguas sino por ser una de las
principales rutas de navegación global
también es una de las zonas más erógenas
del planeta primero porque china
colecciona ahí pleitos territoriales con
media docena de países
la célebre línea de nueve puntos con la
que china reclama el 90 por ciento de
sus aguas centra el debate los países
vecinos las respetaron durante décadas y
en eso ve china el reconocimiento tácito
a sus derechos históricos que
prevalecería sobre las recientes
sentencias de la justicia internacional
y segundo porque eeuu ha elegido el
pacífico como el escenario para
discutirle la primacía global inminente
de china hasta ahí ha desplazado al
grueso de su ejército para que barcos y
aviones se pasen por aguas que china
reclama como propias son ejercicios de
libertad de navegación para hacer
cumplir la legislación internacional
señala washington son intolerables
violaciones territoriales responde china
expertos alertan del peligro de que
alguno de los roces periódicos acabe
derivando en un conflicto serio
la corte de arbitraje de la haya rechazó
el 2016 los derechos que se asigna
chinas sobre un pedazo de mar de 3,5
millones de kilómetros cuadrados al sur
de la potencia asiática que están más
cerca de filipinas de brunei de malasia
de taiwán y de vietnam la haya ratificó
su posición en julio de este año pero
china sigue haciendo caso omiso en juego
esta una ruta comercial por donde pasan
casi 3,4 billones de dólares el 40 por
ciento del gas natural líquido en el
mundo y 3.200 hectáreas en islas
artificiales que está construyendo china
y donde hace pruebas militares en este
mar también hay grandes reservas de
combustibles fósiles que muchos países
de la región quieren explotar pero que
china lo impide con su presencia militar
ya través de ayuda internacional a estos
países precisamente respecto a eeuu ha
incrementado su presencia militar en la
zona y apoyo a un acuerdo entre las
partes para asegurar el flujo marítimo
entre otras cosas
desde hace décadas países como malasia
vietnam filipinas han tratado de
urbanizar poco a poco pequeñas islas
remotas del mar de china meridional que
consideran parte de sus respectivos
territorios ya fuera construyendo
edificios o ganando terreno al mar estos
países han tratado así de cimentar su
soberanía sobre estos territorios y
sobre todo sobre las aguas que los
rodean de cara a controlar las rutas
comerciales que transitan por ellas o
sus bancos de pesca o posibles
yacimientos de recursos energéticos sin
embargo el ritmo y la velocidad con la
que china ha comenzado a urbanizar
también islas en la zona en la última
década ha cambiado radicalmente el
panorama especialmente en lugares como
spratly o las paracelso archipiélagos
que formados por cientos de pequeños
arrecifes e islas cuya soberanía se
disputan tanto el gobierno de pekín como
el de hanoi manila o incluso taipei
china ha sido el único país hasta ahora
que ha construido en estas islas grandes
instalaciones militares y también
sistemas de armamento algo que ha
deparado duras críticas de todos estos
vecinos y también de países europeos y
eeuu que dicen mostrarse preocupados por
de navegación en la zona